The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: So I've
got a list of things
I'm hoping to do today.
I'll begin with a few final
words about saddle points.
The reason I'm interested
in saddle points
is when we get to this
deep learning direction,
you know that the
big step there is
finding a minimum of the total
cost function and gradient
descent, which we'll
certainly discuss
as the usual method or
stochastic gradient descent.
And all kinds of
issues arise, what
happens if you have a saddle
point or a degenerate minimum?
All these possibilities and the
understanding of deep learning
is focusing more
and more on what
does that the gradient
descent algorithm produce.
So I just thought minima
and maxima we know about.
Saddle points are kind
of a little hazier.
So this is a perfect example.
And I'll just say a few
more words about it.
Then, I want to
talk about the Lab 3
that I boldly posted
on the Stellar
and also about projects, just
to get us thinking about those.
And then my real math topic
for today and this week
is basic ideas of
statistics, particularly
the covariance matrix.
I'm sure you've met
mean and variance.
Those are the most used words.
And we'll use them again.
But then I want to
go on to covariance.
So that's what's coming today--
a few words on
saddle points, a lot
of words about the
lab and anything
you want to ask about projects,
and then some basic statistics.
OK, saddle point so
the example I'm taking
is this Rayleigh quotient.
And I'm taking a
simple matrix S.
I might as well take
a diagonal matrix.
It's symmetric, of course.
And any symmetric matrix I
could just change variables
by a cube matrix,
an orthogonal matrix
to get to something like that.
And then the x, we're in 3D.
So we got a sort of
manageable size here.
And the x vector is uvw.
So this is the quotient.
x transpose x, you
see is just exactly
5 u squareds, 3 v
squareds, and 1 w squared.
And I divide by the length
to normalize things.
So what are the
main facts that we
know that I'm not
going to prove,
but what are the main facts?
What's the maximum value of R?
What's the minimum value
of R, of that function?
And is there a saddle point?
So saddle of R.
OK, what's the maximum value?
How large could you make
that ratio, capital R?
I just think, you
know, this isn't
a standard topic in 18.06.
But with an example like this,
you'll see the whole point.
OK, so how large could I make R?
Yeah, go ahead and say it.
AUDIENCE: Sigma.
GILBERT STRANG: Sigma 1.
And what is it here?
Let's just do with
these numbers.
How big can I make that ratio R?
And what choice of
uvw makes it big?
So how big I can get it is?
AUDIENCE: 5.
GILBERT STRANG: 5.
That ratio can't be more than 5.
You see it would be 5.
Well, how do I get to 5?
Maximum of R is 5.
And what is the uvw that--
so I'll say at--
what choice of uvw
would give us 5 here?
You see it immediately, 1, 0, 0.
And what about the minimum of R?
The minimum of this ratio, how
do I make that ratio small?
Well, I put I load stuff on
the w instead of loading it up
on to u.
It's just clear.
So what is the
minimum value of R?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 1, because
I'll load everything into w.
So the minimum value will be 1.
And that will be at
the vector 0, 0, 1.
I've loaded everything there.
And then the point of
this short discussion
is, is there another place
where the derivatives,
first derivatives,
of R are all zero?
That's where, of course,
the first derivatives
are 0 at the max, at the min.
But we also have
three variables here.
And we're going to
find a third point.
And what is that point?
You probably guess.
And what will be
the saddle value?
So you have to see some
kind of a surface that--
I guess, what are we in?
4D.
So we have base
coordinates, uvw.
And R goes vertically.
And we plot that surface.
And we don't really understand
it unless we think a lot about
it, which we haven't.
But we can pretty well
guess what's what.
And so what do you think
is the saddle value?
And where is it
going to be reached?
Everybody is going
to tell me correctly.
Saddle value would be?
Three at this middle point.
And what are these three
with respect to the matrix?
They're its eigenvectors.
What are these three numbers
with respect to the matrix?
There its eigenvalues.
That's why that
Rayleigh quotient
is such an important function.
It's kind of a messy function.
If you take its
derivative, you've
got to use the quotient rule
or use Lagrange multiplier.
That's the way to make
it more manageable.
But it's kind of messy.
But the results
could not be better.
The values there
are the eigenvalues.
And the places where you reach
them are the eigenvectors.
And so the max is
the most important.
So that's sigma 1.
Here's sigma 3-- or
lambda and sigma,
because the matrix is
symmetric positive definite.
And here in the
middle is sigma 2.
And if we want to
compute eigenvectors,
which I'm not
planning to do today,
just to make this remark--
computing eigenvectors, getting
the largest one or the smallest
one is a lot quicker in
general than getting these ones
in the middle.
You have to use good
codes and pay attention
to computing those
saddle point values.
So is there anything nice I
can do with saddle points?
How does one think
about saddle points?
So again, saddle
point is defined
by first derivatives equals 0.
That's-- and the
second derivatives--
OK, so that's a matrix.
Here's a vector,
the gradient vector.
The derivative
with respect to u,
the derivative with respect
to v, NDR DW, just a vector.
And all those
components are zero.
The gradient vector is zero.
But what about
second derivatives?
Well, that's getting more.
There are nine of
those now, because I've
got Ruu, second derivative
with respect to u.
But I've got mixed derivative.
Second derivative of R
with respect to Du Dv.
So I have a 3 by 3 matrix.
Fortunately, that
matrix is symmetric,
because we're blessed
by that wonderful fact
that the derivative
with respect to u
and then v is the
same as v and then u.
So we get a symmetric matrix.
Well, I won't write
it down, but it's
got the maximum, minimum, and
saddle information built in.
Here's this one
additional thought
that I want to communicate
about saddle points,
because it's really
nice to somehow get back
to maxima and minima.
So this idea for
a saddle point is
to be able to write it as
the maximum of a minimum.
So let me do that,
and then I'm all done.
So I'm going to say that
lambda 2, that value,
is the maximum of over something
of the minimum over something
of x trans of our function.
Now, of course, I have to tell
you what you're maximizing over
and what you're minimizing over.
But that's the idea
is that one way
to get into the middle
place there where
the saddles are sitting is to
have a maximum of a minimum.
And that leads-- that's what
I'm about to complete here--
would lead you, for
example, very quickly
to the interlacing theorem that
I spoke about for eigenvalues
and for singular values
of when you perturb S
or when you throw away
a row and column of S.
The eigenvalues go in between.
That is the kind of
conclusion that this max min
stuff is set up to produce.
So here, let me just tell
you what it would be.
I'm aiming to get lambda 2.
So I'm going to take a maximum
over two dimensional spaces--
subspaces of R3.
We're in 3D.
So you can see that's sort
of like 2-dimensional spaces.
Let me give that subspace
a name like V. That'll do.
Cap V, everybody can
see that that's a cap V.
And then this will be
the minimum over V.
So it's is kind of tricky.
So I take any subspace
that's two dimensional.
And I'll take one in a moment.
And I'll figure out the minimum.
Well, suppose I take
this subspace V,
which is spanned
by the first two--
it's supposed to
be a 2D subspace--
spanned by the first.
Suppose I try example.
The span of 1, 0,
0, and 0, 1, 0.
In other words, all
vectors u, v, 0.
That's a 2D space.
What is the minimum of
that Rayleigh quotient
over that two-dimensional space?
So now I'm taking a minimum.
I don't have to think
about saddle points.
So I'm looking at the
thing, but w is zero now.
Everybody sees that I've
squeezed it down to 2D.
So w is zero.
So what is the minimum now?
So this thing would become--
for this space-- would
become the 5u squared
and the 3v squared over the
u squared plus the v squared,
but the W is 0.
So what's the minimum of that?
AUDIENCE: 3.
GILBERT STRANG: 3.
3.
OK, the minimum is 3 for
this particular space.
Let me call it V special.
For that particular space,
the minimum is 3, correct?
Everybody sees that.
Because I just have u and v
to play with, the 5 and the 3.
So if I put everything
into v, I get to 3.
And now, I take the maximum.
So the maximum is at least 3,
because this particular choice
of V gave me the answer 3.
And now, I'm taking the maximum
over all possible 2D spaces.
And I got 3 for one of
the possible spaces of V.
And I might get higher
than 3 for some other one.
But actually I don't.
The truth is that
this turns out to be
3 which is, of course,
exactly what we wanted.
So I'm saying that this
particular two-dimensional
space, the minimum of
over that, minimum,
the minimum there is 3.
And now, I maximize
over all others.
And so the idea is
that for any other one,
the minimum value
will be below 3.
And, therefore, when I go for
the max of the mins, I get 3.
So I just repeat that
and then be quiet
about this whole subject.
So it's a maximum over subspaces
of a minimum of the Rayleigh
quotient.
If that subspace is exactly
the perfect choice, this one,
I get the value 3.
And I'm claiming that's the
biggest value I can get,
because if I pick
any other subspace--
what if I picked
a subspace that--
suppose another v would
be all vectors 0, v, w.
What would I get for the
minimum of this thing?
But now w is in the picture
and u is not in the picture.
What I get for
the minimum there?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 1.
I'd get 1.
The minimum would be when
I put everything into w
and I got one.
And then when I take the
max, it's not a winner.
It's thrown out.
The winner will be the
that space and the 3.
So I guess I'm hoping
that you sort of see
in this small example that you
can express this middle saddle
value as--
it's reasonable to think of it
as a maximum in some directions
and a minimum in another.
Think of the-- well, try to
think of some surface, which
is going up in some direction.
So it's a minimum
in those directions.
And it's going down
in other directions.
So it's a max in
those directions.
And saddle points is perched
in there right at that place,
at the saddle point.
You know, if you're
like hiking from here
to California or
something, you're
going to pass a saddle point.
Actually, you see
it on the Mass--
the Mass Pike has an
amazing little sign.
I don't know if
you've noticed it.
If you drive west on the
Mass Pike, pretty far west
of Boston, there's a little
sign telling you the altitude
or elevation, whatever.
And it says there this is
the highest point until you
reach the Rockies basically.
I'd say like, OK, Midwest
is pretty flat, right?
Because that's a long way away.
You don't think of
Massachusetts as like really
in the big league
with high spots.
But there it is.
It's the highest
one until you get--
and I think it tells you
where the next one will
be in Colorado.
Anyway, those highest
points tend to be saddles.
The very, very highest point--
where's that in
Alaska or somewhere--
that's a max, of
course, by definition.
But there are a lot of saddle
points in other places.
And those would be maxima of
minima or minima of maxima.
Good.
I'm stopping there.
We might see this again when
we start gradient descent.
But at least,
because saddle points
don't come up much
in teaching calculus,
I thought that was good.
OK, second point
is models, Lab 3,
and projects, anything you'd
like to ask about projects.
So, please, this is
your chance to ask.
You could also ask by email.
If you have suggested
or idea for our project,
let me encourage you or a team
to work on it or just yourself.
And if you want to
think, OK, shall I
get some feedback of
does this sound sensible?
Any suggestions?
Send me an email.
I'd be happy to--
of course, I'm a total
beginner here, too.
When I created this Lab
3, I was like desperate,
not for model 1.
For model 1, have
you looked at--
it's reached Stellar.
And it's only one printed page.
Have people had a look at this?
So I'll just repeat quickly.
Model 1 is an example
where of overfitting.
And what's going
on with model 1?
So model 1 says take--
5 would be enough, but I
probably said 10 or something.
So I'll make it six points.
And put a curve through them.
So if you put a curve--
and the curve is going
to be a polynomial.
So we're going to set
a fit by polynomial.
Everybody knows polynomial is
C0 plus C1x plus whatever CK
x to the K, let's say.
For K equals 0--
well, I don't know
if I even ask 0.
That would be the
best straight line.
That would run
along the average.
K equal to 1, that would
be a straight line fit.
And you would compute
that by least squares,
because of course no
straight line is going
to go through all the points.
You're going to have some
error by least squares.
2 would be fitting
by a parabola.
Again, you'll have some error,
but smaller since parabolas
include straight lines.
So you can only reduce the
total sum of squares error
by going to a degree two.
Degree 3 and up to--
how many points shall we take?
1, 2-- let me just use the
same letter I've used here.
Well, m is the number
of points, but m
varies between 1 point I
guess and probably n point.
Maybe K here.
Up to n-- up to 6, let's say.
And I want to make
a comment about 6.
No, 5 would do it.
Degree 5 will fit the 6 points
that we've got 6 points here.
But if I stop at degree
5, I was better there,
because degree 5 polynomial
also has a constant term.
So it really has
six coefficients.
So there is a 1
degree 5 polynomial
with six numbers, six
coefficients, that
goes through those six points.
And so it's a perfect fit.
That would be an
exact fit of the data.
So here's the data.
Create a polynomial of degree 5
that goes through those points
exactly.
And look at the result.
And what would you
see if you look at the result?
Would it be smooth?
Of course, it's a polynomial.
Would it be nice?
No, it will be horrible.
To get through those points--
did I get six points?
Yeah.
To get through those
points, I'm guessing
that that fifth degree
polynomial, the perfect fit,
is an example that
occurs to practically
everybody of
overfitting, because
making that decision,
perfect fit, learn the data,
training data exactly
will send a polynomial--
I don't know what it looks like.
I don't want to-- well,
I do want to know,
but not right now.
Anyway, craziness.
And, of course,
I'm going to ask--
it doesn't look
like that probably--
I'm going to ask you
to plot the results.
Well, what's the least
squares error when
you fit by a straight line?
When you fit by horizontal
line, a constant,
fit by a straight line,
move up to parabolas,
move up to a cubics?
But when you hit this, you're
not making any error at all.
You're not really needing
to use least squares.
You can solve Ax
equals B. Ac equal b.
So this is the b thing.
And c is the vector
of coefficients.
And the matrix A is bad
news when it's a 6 by 6,
when you get up
to a complete fit.
And I guess what I
wanted just to see is--
a lot of things I don't know,
like suppose I change six to 20
or something.
Then I'm pretty sure that
out there at 18, 19, 20,
this thing is
really off the map.
And you could compute
its max and you'd
see a very big number.
But, of course, for
a straight line,
that would be pretty safe.
The slope would be
pretty moderate.
And I don't know where you--
so that's probably
underfitting to try
to fit this by a straight line.
It's not as close
as you would want.
But fitting by a full perfect
filling, a high degree
polynomial, is
certainly overfitting.
Where is the boundary?
I'm sure people know
about this, but I
think it is something
we could learn from.
So that's what that
model 1 is about.
And just to make
one final comment,
that matrix A has
a name in the case
where it's a square matrix,
where you're fitting exactly--
interpolating would be the word.
So that exact fit,
that corresponds
to square matrix A. And the
word for it is interpolation.
And I guess it's Lagrange again.
Seeing that guy too often here.
So it would be Lagrange
interpretation.
But the matrix has
a different name.
And whose name is
associated with that matrix?
AUDIENCE: Vandermonde.
GILBERT STRANG: Vandermonde.
Vandermonde.
So this is the square
matrix, which was--
so let me write it.
It's called a
Vandermonde matrix.
And it's a matrix that
has a crazy large inverse,
because just as I'm saying,
the C that comes out
from the perfect fit,
from the interpolation,
from the square matrix,
the C is going to be giant.
And so you will construct a
matrix, of course, to do this,
and it will be
identical to the--
so we've heard this
word Vandermonde
matrix in this class
within the last week.
Anybody remember where the word
Vandermonde came up in class?
It was in professor
Townsend's lecture.
So you could go
back to that video
if you wanted as an
example of a matrix which
had a horrible inverse,
a giant matrix.
The Hilbert matrix
was another example.
I think he did two examples,
Vandermonde and Hilbert.
So this Vandermonde matrix--
I could write it down, but
I'll leave that to you--
has a big inverse.
And its eigenvalues--
well, no singular values,
because it's not symmetric--
it's singular values
are way scattered.
It has tiny little
singular values
plus an ordinary
sized singular values.
So that's the example that I
just think you could go with.
And as far as I can see, sending
it to auto grader as a Julia
file, it would be
even worse than usual,
sending it to auto grader.
I think it wouldn't know what
to do as far as I can see.
So I'm thinking of submissions
coming to Gradescope.
And I'm thinking of
some plots to show
what happens as K increases
and some tables of data maybe
and then maybe a paragraph of
conclusion, like what degree
is safe and when
does it become risky
and when does it
become disaster.
So stuff like that.
Really, these are sort
of open-ended labs
and you use any language.
Questions about that example?
Which is really that's what
I'm expecting to be ready
and quite a good example for
Wednesday after the break.
Question?
Anyway, you can email me.
You probably see that see
what the model looks like.
Then the second one I've taken
that first jump into, networks.
Made a very simple network
without any hidden layers
at all actually.
And just wrote down
what I think might work.
But you may find that you
want to modify model 2.
Go for it.
I don't have any patent or
personal stake in the way model
2 is written.
But the idea is fit data--
well, start with data, but
don't make it too perfect,
because we want some
learning to happen here.
So it's the
classification problem.
So it won't be least squares
with variables like u and v
and w.
It's just plus 1 or
minus 1, or 1, 0,
or cat and dog, whatever
that classification is.
So that's the basic problem to
start with in deep learning.
For quite a long time,
that's the natural problem.
So it's a
classification problem.
And the description
here suggests one way
to set up that training data
and execute a neural net
like experiment, but without
getting very far away
from ordinary linear algebra.
So as I say, if you want
to change this, develop it
further, get some
ideas about it,
that's what the
whole point is here.
Actually, the faculty meeting
this week, maybe today--
what's today?
AUDIENCE: Wednesday.
GILBERT STRANG: Wednesday?
Yeah, so it's this afternoon.
And the faculty
doesn't come to much.
Of course, it's late
in the afternoon.
But faculty meeting
this afternoon
is about MIT's plans for
requirements or courses
in computational thinking.
And in a way, this course
within the math department
is among the ones that
are in that direction.
Of course, in other departments,
those are further along.
Anyway, when Raj Rao taught
the course last spring,
he had the Julia system
better developed.
And it was a chance to bring
computers and bring laptops
and do things in class.
And you'll have that
chance again when
he visits in a month.
OK, enough.
And I'm open to questions
about the project.
Should I maybe ask you to email
me a rough idea of a project?
And tell me if
you are in a group
or if you would like to find
a group, maybe two or three
people.
I'm not thinking
of groups of 50.
Two or three would be sensible.
Questions about projects?
I mean, I just introduced
this idea of our project,
and I apologize for not
bringing it up the first week.
But I just couldn't see--
I don't want to do
exams on linear algebra.
We passed that point.
So this seemed the
right way to go.
But I'm not looking
for a PhD thesis here.
Questions?
Thoughts?
I guess I hope you
know you can ask.
Yeah, oh good.
AUDIENCE: So could
you maybe describe
the scope of the project?
GILBERT STRANG: Right.
How will I-- yeah, so the
scope is connected to the time
that you would devote to it.
And what should I
say about scope?
Maybe the equivalent of
three homeworks or something.
Because I'll tamp down homeworks
as project date gets closer.
Does that give an idea?
So it's not infinite, but it's
not something tiny and trivial.
Yeah, good.
AUDIENCE: Do you have an
example projects of what
were done in past years?
GILBERT STRANG: Well,
that's the thing.
There aren't really past years.
We are the ones.
So I will have next year if
contribute some good ideas.
Maybe I should I
ask Professor Rao
to maybe send us the
projects he uses in Michigan?
That would be some ideas.
But remember that he
hasn't, up to now anyway,
moved the course
toward deep learning.
He did other topics, all
of which would be fine.
But quite a few people
have had some 6.036
or know something about
conventional neural nets.
And I'm certainly excited
to get to that topic.
So the project could get
there or it could not.
Both totally fine.
OK, that's a good idea.
I'll ask Raj for
just the projects--
and you'll recognize a couple,
because you've done a couple.
But there are a bunch more.
Then there was another
question or thought?
And I'm remembering that I
think maybe everybody got
an email or a
Stellar announcement
that some members of the class
took an initiative, which
was wonderful, to open
the possibility of people
just showing up one evening a
week in the Media Lab was it?
Or was there a location?
And has it happened or
is it a future event?
AUDIENCE: It happened.
GILBERT STRANG: It happened.
But I hadn't
mentioned it in class,
so probably you didn't have--
and we're not really
into projects yet,
so it was probably
a quiet evening?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
GILBERT STRANG: Yeah.
Yeah, and that's--
AUDIENCE: Productive but quiet.
GILBERT STRANG:
Productive but quiet.
OK.
So will it happen again?
AUDIENCE: Sure, I
think maybe now we'll
be looking after spring break.
GILBERT STRANG:
After spring break.
OK, so post again on Stellar
the plan for the next meeting
that people could come to.
So this is David Anderton,
so you'll recognize his name.
And did you have the
meeting in the Media Lab?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we had it
on the Thursday and Friday.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So with the break
coming and spring
hopefully coming after
today's potential storm,
when we come back, good.
OK.
Is that good?
I hope some of that is helpful.
You'll get an idea.
You're seeing about
as much as I know,
which is model 1 is definitely
doable and very significant.
And Vandermonde matrices and
so on are truly important.
And their instability
is a big issue.
But then moving toward weights
and training data and test data
is where we want to go.
Good.
OK.
So do I have some time?
I do just to speak about
mean and variance, the two
golden words of statistics--
and covariance, the
matrix, the intersection
of linear algebra with
statistics, and then
some famous inequality.
So I'll continue
with this on Friday
and post some other material.
So that it's coming from
a later section of notes.
OK, can I just so I either
have probabilities P1 up to Pn
adding to 1, or I have our
continuous distribution
of probabilities, maybe from
all x's from minus infinity
to infinity, again, giving 1.
Let me work with the
discrete example.
That's where people
naturally start.
So what is the mean?
So I've n possible outcomes
with those probabilities.
And I can ask you
about the sample mean
or I can ask you about
the expected mean.
So the sample means,
we've done an experiment.
We've got some output.
The expected mean means
we know probabilities,
but we haven't used them yet.
So this uses actual output.
And the sample mean is simply--
shall I just say,
m for mean-- well,
these two are
importantly different.
One is something where
you've done the experiment.
And this is before
you do the experiment.
And the letters get-- maybe
mu, I'll change it to mu.
I don't want to use S because
S gets used with variance.
So it's just the average,
average output from the sample.
Like I've flipped a
coin a million times.
And the output was 0 or 1.
So I got a million 1s and 0s.
And I take the average, and I'm
expecting a number like half
a million.
Of course, I'm thinking
of a fair coin.
And the law of
large numbers would
say that this sample mean does
approach 1/2 with probability 1
as the number of
samples gets larger.
So sample mean is
straightforward.
The expected mean means--
these are actual sample outputs.
They happened, whereas the
expected mean is just the--
and I'll use m for that--
it's the probability of the
first output times that output
plus the probability of the
second output times that output
plus, plus Pn xn.
So that will approach that with
probability 1 as this number
capital N-- notice
the difference.
Capital N here is the number of
samples, the number of trials.
And it gets big.
We keep doing things
more and more.
This little n is the number
of possible different outputs
with their probabilities.
And there you see it.
And, of course, in
the continuous case,
we would take the
interval of x p of x dx.
So let me just, by
analogy, that you
should know what the
continuous version is
and what the
discrete version is.
OK, that's the mean.
Now, for variance.
Sample variance-- and, shall
I say, expected variance?
I don't know.
Just variance is what
people would usually say.
I don't know if I've remembered
the right word there,
sample variance.
Is that-- I included this
topic in linear algebra book.
Anyway, yeah.
OK.
So what's the sample variance?
So I guess I'm--
hm-- yeah, so what is
the sample variance?
What's the variance
about anyway?
What's the key
point of variance?
It's the distance from the mean.
So this will be a distance
from the sample mean,
and this will be a distance
from the expected mean.
So not distance from zero,
but distance from mu and m,
from the center of the thing.
So the sample variance--
so, again, we have n samples.
But for some wonderful
reason in statistics
you divide by n
minus 1 this time.
And the reason has to do with
the fact that you used one--
this will involve the mean.
So this would be
the first output
minus mu squared up to the
n-th output minus mu squared.
So it's the average
distance from mu--
average squared
but with this little twist that,
of course, when n is large,
it's not a very significant
difference between n and n
minus 1.
I Think that's about right.
All this is that I'm just doing
one experiment over and over.
Covariance, which
is the deeper idea,
is where linear
algebra comes in.
I have a matrix because why?
Because I'm doing multiple
experiments at the same time.
I'm flipping two coins.
I'm flipping 15 coins.
I'm doing other things.
So that will be covariances when
I'm doing several experiments
at once.
That will involve
matrices of that size.
So what's the variance?
I should have given
you the usual notation.
The expected value of x,
that's what's the mean.
And here, I'm looking at
the expected value of what?
So when I'm computing a
variance, using probabilities--
so I'm using expectations,
not trial runs--
expectations means
use the probabilities.
And it's the expectation
of the distance
from x to the mean squared.
And that is when I'm doing is an
expectation for a discrete set,
I think of the probability,
the first probability,
that goes with an output x1
and a second probability that
goes with an output x2.
And each time I subtract
from the mean and square.
So that's the variance that
everybody calls sigma squared.
Now, two minutes left is
enough to say a few more
words about covariance.
Oh, to get to
covariance, I really
have to speak about
joint probabilities.
That's a key idea--
So I'm doing two
experiments at once.
So each one has its
own probabilities.
But together, I have to ask--
so here are two easy cases.
Suppose I'm flipping two coins.
So that I might get heads heads.
I may get heads
tails, tails heads,
or tails tails,
four possibility,
four possible outputs
there, four possible pairs.
And if you're flipping one coin
and I'm flipping another one,
those are independent results.
Those are independent results.
There won't be a
covariance where
by knowing what my flip
was I would know more
about your flip.
But now, the other
possibility would
be to glue the coins together.
Now, if I do a flip, they
always come up heads and heads
or tails and tails.
So the heads tails
combination is not possible.
In fact, one output is totally
dependent on the other outputs.
So that's the other extreme.
We have independent
outputs with covariance 0,
and we have totally
dependent outputs
when the things are just glued
together, when one result tells
us what the other
result is, then
that's a situation where
the covariance is a maximum.
It couldn't be bigger than that.
And say in polling, if
you were polling a family,
say political
polling, well, there
would be some covariance
expected there.
The two or three
or five people that
are living in the
same house wouldn't
be independent,
entirely independent,
but nor would all five
give the same answer.
So their covariance matrix
would have some off diagonal,
but it would still
be invertible.
And actually, what I wanted
to tell you about next time
at the start is that
covariance matrix, which
I have to define for you, will
be symmetric positive definite,
or semidefinite.
What's the semidefinite case?
Of course, that's the case where
the coins are glued together.
OK, thanks.
So you know what's
coming Friday.
I know that holiday
is also coming Friday.
And just you'll
make a good plan,
and I'll move on
after the break.
Good.